[Music]
for this next fight with Nate Diaz this
is a little unusual you have had to put
on weight to get into his weight class
is that right there was a decision
whether he would come down to your white
class or you would go to his there are
some fighters that would say I'm not
going to do that I don't comfortable
going up to what do you get up to a
hundred and seventy pounds it's 170 I'm
the 145 pound champion but this is at
170 pounds but you know they all claim
they want to fight me or they want this
fight but when my current upon my
previous opponent pulled out then
everyone went silent so Diaz was the
only one that engaged in the
conversation but even then he was still
looking for his way as he he wasn't
happy with the money so we resolved the
money issue then he said he couldn't
make the weight he could only make 160
pounds we agree to that then he came
back again and said I can only make 165
pounds so then I said relax get
comfortable put your feet up you can
weigh in 170 pound on the scales the
weight means no difference to me I'm
still gonna slap the head off him so
entry into warfare weight is a non-issue
so so what's the weight difference gonna
be between you two he's a six please his
body type is kind of weird he's like a
skinny he's like a fat skinny guy you
know like he's skinny but he's fat at
the same time so and but he's tall he's
got range but I feel good at this weight
I like this morning I had two breakfasts
I was I was running late for the last
press conference area or for the press
conferences earlier today and I was
because I had that second breakfast so
and I'm not complaining about the weight
okay his manager just called now he
wants to have a big stick in the ring
how many things but he could he pile on
and you'd still say okay yeah i'm i want
a nice
you